exactly what are the main objectives of
fasting
alhamdulillah there are many objectives
of fasting I'll just list the main ones
number one is seeking the pleasure of
Allah subhana tala number two is to
obtain tawa to acquire tawa that is God
Consciousness pety righteousness and you
can say when you acire tawa but natural
when you learn tawa automatically even
the pledge of Allah comes in it so the
first one can be included in the second
one the third
is for entering Jenna we fast for
entering Jenna number four is for the
expiration of our
sins number five is to seek the reward
of Allah subhana wa tala number six is
for the Forgiveness of our sins if we
fast Allah forgives our
sins number
seven to acquire a sh that is the right
to intercede the right for intercession
if we fast the fast will intercede on
the day of judgment for us
number eight it
is to realize the bounties of Allah
subhana tala number nine to increase our
willpower and our
determination number 10 it is to acquire
Good Deeds number
11 is to gain more
honesty number
12 it is to decrease
our desire diminish one's desire number
13 to narrow the passage of the Satan
fasting Narrows the passage of the
city number 14 to act as a shield
fasting is a shield for the believer
number 15 to abstain from false
speech and number 16 to abstain from
false actions these are the major
objectives of fasting